creativity is really important for me as
like a future job as a part of my future
job i would want to um do something that
changes and then i can use
problem-solving skills constantly um i
feel like when i make animations or when
i figure out how to explain something
i'm
really like that i love that because
it's there's so many different solutions
but knowing that you can try to find and
experiment with different ones and maybe
create something beautiful is um really
i don't know inspiring to me
mathematicals is an educational
initiative that i co-founded with fellow
mathematician jess williams and what
we're trying to do is make maths fun and
accessible and encourage more girls to
pursue careers in maths
so creativity is essential here because
we're trying to think of ways that
people will will enjoy maths and and it
will be fun and accessible to them so
different creative techniques that we've
been using are trying to present
mathematical
problems in
fun short videos
and that explain the problem in a way
that everybody will understand and will
make them want to learn more and
discover more about the topics that
we're talking about i'm really lucky
that i get to be creative every day
in my work and i have been since
i got into this field of data science so
in general across the last decade my
work has really been about
designing and testing innovative ways to
capture human behavior within game-based
assessments
so my collaborators and i from the time
i was in graduate school to now use a
variety of different modeling techniques
from various fields we'll pull things
from engineering
aerospace
you know more basic mathematical models
to help us achieve this goal
we get to think outside the box we get
to think about how we can pull in
different types of thinking from
different fields to help us better
understand
human behavior human cognition
learning
so it's really exciting and really novel
and it's something that because of the
field that i'm in i've been able to do
this now for for multiple years
[Music]